the president will visit New Orleans on
Monday to address the American Farm
Bureau just as farmers are beginning to
feel the impact of the government
shutdown about nine and a half billion
dollars in federal aid was set aside to
help farmers across the country whether
the trade dispute with China
well those federal aid checks are now on
hold Dean Reynolds is in Polk City Iowa
who spoke to a farmer who needs help
after the price of his crops dropped by
20 percent
Aaron layman is not a federal employees
an Iowa farmer but the government
shutdown has put him in a real bind this
is our soybeans typically this time of
year will go in just to check check them
to make sure they're not spoiling or
they're staying in good condition you're
not kidding yeah it's a 30-foot bin when
it's full it holds about 10,000 bushels
layman has watched the price of his
soybeans dropped 20% since last summer
when the Trump administration got into a
fight over trade with China so the price
drop off on soybeans together with the
government shutdown is like a double
whammy
it really is got us coming and going
this adds just another layer of
uncertainty to oh absolutely we rely on
our USDA folks the government shutdown
means farmers are sort of flying blind
lacking the supply and demand
information that the now-closed
Agriculture Department would be
providing them and allowing them to plan
ahead in three months these dusty field
should be filled with crops but how much
to plant no one is really sure the
government was in the midst of
subsidizing farmers for lost markets in
China but the payments were suspended
when the government shut down that sides
not too bad a farmer for 25 years layman
wonders how it's come to this it's not
worth putting up the wall to put us in
this situation
it's just over a thousand miles from his
pokécity acres to Washington DC but the
reverberations from the border wall
stalemate are hitting him hard we're
used to weather factors being out of our
control we try to deal with those as
best we can the patience runs thins for
farmers when it seems like there are a
crisis that's invented or something that
could be completely avoided that makes
no sense really makes farmers
exasperated and they are not alone for
CBS this morning Dean Reynolds Polk City
Iowa